you could potentially be one of many and  you don't want you don't like being you  don't mind being one of many there's  probably some guys across the years that  I've always probably tried to holler at  you tried to take you out and you  haven't given any time to These Guys  these ordinary ordinary I don't know but  it's fine but what I'm trying to say all  of these guys have watched you deal with  all these guys one by one one by one and  it never amounts to nothing at some  point you need to say to yourself maybe  I am going for the wrong types of guy  maybe this guy is not right for me maybe  I need to stop going for what I like and  maybe I need to stock up for what makes  sense